in the previous segment of our panel
discussion on ethnicity and conflict we
talked about the economic dimension and
in particular the question about whether
certain conflicts that are widely viewed
as ethnic may actually be economic
conflicts in disguise that segue into a
larger discussion of multiculturalism
and multicultural societies which
Richard crisp kicked off taking this now
towards the nation of via most cultural
society what how these multiculturalism
good is it is diversity a cause of
conflict in our societies or is it if it
age a way of assumed winter with Harley
I think the the evidence on on this day
is next soap on one hand we know that
contact between is not going to be
powerful way to reduce pressures they've
been over 500 studies of hundred contact
our publicist but it shows us that
entities that this is the case though is
basic fundamental correlation between
into the contact names building these
kind of ameliorate media relations
between groups and tolerance but on the
other hand it's precisely when and then
coming back to what we was talking about
earlier vice precisely when groups are
in the same proximity or occupy
occupying the same space that we see
these companies conflicts erupts
inspector hound and you square disparity
in terms of policy to try and promote
multiculturalism a valuing of diversity
again is not necessarily the picture so
we know that trying to promote most cops
ISM getting people super to be hard to
value difference this can be purchased
at the same time it makes me fun in to
do stadium and make salient those
stereotypes and perhaps negative
stereotypes which are part of a problem
or not you can become be to affect
coming back to this idea of its be kind
of conflict with resources minority
groups tend to prefer multicultural
policy
but majority groups have seasons of fat
especially if they're higher I'd enta
fire hi ethnic or national enterprise so
they're real challenges to getting
people to embrace the notion of multiple
notion that we can live in a society but
is celebrating values well I mean based
on what you're saying is it sounds to me
like one wonders why you would pursue a
multicultural policy at all I mean is
there can you can you address that I
mean I mean you have sort of been
addressing it but it seems almost like
like it what you're saying seems to
argue against multicultural policies
well the the opposite of the oxygen
recited opposites and multi cultural
policies in color black Protestant where
you or difference attend ameri- system
and we know that there's also evidence
to suggest that that just doesn't work
and one of the reasons that has Marcus
Vickers that again coming back to some
of the things we've been discussing
people's identity died unfortunately our
density define and so they find in the
defining in a long route from you and
another group from there this is
important to my definition of my
identity so and there's lots of research
shows that in strictly controlled
laboratory conditions who try and
eliminate these basics but expectation
even these mineral basis for with Nana
shape which you created in the live
auction you try and tend those away from
people then it's quite how to do and
people don't want to give up that sense
of identity so in colored lines
approaches generally as they not want to
be the way forth and we should be we
should be celebrating diversity it's not
about abandoning multi cultures and lots
of positives it's working out how to get
it to work how to get people to value
well that does sort of edge us into you
know in entered into talking about about
how we address ethnic violence and and
and these kinds of car you know
driven conflict and I would be curious
if people could sort of now talk about
what I guess what you would do if you if
you could do one thing for example to to
kind of ameliorate intergroup conflict
of this type from the perspective of
your science for example um maybe maybe
Richard we can just start with you
through um well one of the things that
we've been arguing is first yeah
although that there is clearly just a
bit quite a bit mobile system for
recognizing recognizing out groups and
detecting out groups and differentiating
in groups and objects and indeed rashmi
theory talks about how this is it was an
adaptive mechanism and we might be facts
if there are also situations from a new
perspective you know in such incest
rebels brilliant environment where one
can imagine it was adapt to put aside
these things and to try and forge
alliances so not just always be thinking
about us and there but actually think of
as a potential ally basic fortitude to
unite against a common enemy or two to
increase the agricultural skills base in
15 so that's an that's in some sense
sort of harnessing the similar innate
desire to kind of affiliate with people
you know to kind of form coalition's
with with other with other people in
your group and then with our be that it
wouldn't be not adapted so I've always
been detecting differences but you
shouldn't have a second system it can
kick in to override those differences
when when it's adaptive to do so so
alongside that that this us versus them
mechanism which we know is adaptive in
many respects we've argued that there is
a second mechanism which enables
coalition building and we know that
there are various situations in which
this is this is triggered so for
instance when this final us-versus-them
criteria doesn't seem to think so for
instance when you encounter a member of
the album but
cast arity where you're at positive way
that you're not expecting to a nap
remember then we see that people shift
the moment things from the ship out of
these kind of heuristic Oscar severe
ways of thinking and into more in-depth
ways of trying to analyze what's the law
and what's happening without them and
Mars arene could you would you care to
comment on that well um Richard is
absolutely right that if you no matter
how far back we go into our evolutionary
history it is clear that while we have
to be highly sensitive two tours in and
out we also have to be ready to form
coalition's with groups of people who
are not originally us okay but we're
having to do that now on a scale that
we've never done before so it is true
that you know 500 years ago a thousand
years ago 50,000 years ago that that we
largely lived amongst people who were
genetically identical to us on the other
side of a mountain were people who were
genetically identical but made a
different grunting noise we looked at
them and they looked at us there was
this question of you know am I going to
be the one who will live tomorrow or
will they but now we look at people who
are absolutely different from us people
who have genetically nothing in common
with us people who are socio-cultural e
quite alien to us and we have to look at
them and say should i outsource to this
room should i can i can i collaborate
with them and beat somebody who's just
like me genetically so this is a a
mandate that our modern world places
that is absolutely not one that our
ancestors have to ever deal with so i'm
going to argue that a preference for
things multicultural a preference for
diversity is not a natural taste it is
like drinking single malt scotch for the
first time when your age 13 and you
steal some of your parents you don't
understand why why adults do this but
but it is an acquired taste
the malt scotch as is a preference for
diversity and that that the two system
thing and that perhaps anything over
time what used to be the foreign or
alien response to difference becomes the
default response you know and and and
you can see this you can see this why is
it that in most countries in the world
people who live along the waterways tend
to be more open to different um you know
probably because strange people can
impair parts of the world with their
wares to sell them and if I came friends
with them and even though that doesn't
happen anymore commerce isn't
necessarily along waterways anymore it
now is the case that people who think
that way live in those parts of world
and they have a a sense that what is
different or what is strange is actually
attractive if that so that again the
reason i think the species still remains
on the planet is because we have both of
these we are naturally and in some ways
insensitive to what might be different
but we know that that going along these
old lines of using that difference to
make alliances simply isn't right if we
have used a simple rule of you know
similarity and difference we would not
be here today
you